welcome to this video who Shang hang
from the UK yeah maybe let's get the
king to save the early Castle on move
four cannot get get to it any quicker I
could play The King's Indian attack here
maybe now with Knight D2 and E4 that's
leading to a interesting play often H
it's taking a
while okay well Bishop B7 is completely
normal yeah Rook
E1
H yeah okay I can pre moove that Rook E1
I need to do anyway even after weird
moves like Knight G4 or
something yeah white is trying to
initiate play on the king side here
Knight F1 Bishop F4 H4 this kind of
thing let's see B5 is the most common
move or that one attacking E5 another
time and additional
time so let's prepare Bishop
F4 yeah black is pushing all his pawns
that's the typical plan
here
B4
A4 this is um Black's
General
agenda um I wonder if I should
play do a play Knight E3 here it is
sometimes an idea to put the Knight on
E3 to have those tactical ideas like
Knight takes
D5 Knight D5 takes E6 h but I don't know
is it is it well placed there in other
cases I mean if black is not exactly
falling into this into this
idea yeah maybe why not Knight can go to
G4 and he cannot take ah okay he's
retreating
voluntarily okay Knight G4 here this
maybe H5
H I cannot sacrifice here right and then
E6 no that's not that's not going to
work but maybe this was interesting now
I have ideas of sacrificing on
H6 it's it's
really that's really dangerous at
times let's see I'm not sure that I'm
threatening it
probably
not
but it's something that black has to
watch out
for um how do I how do I get more
Firepower into
that he has it he has everything
protected at the
moment maybe I have to really play G4 G5
yes
h i don't get anywhere with pieces here
I really have to play G4
G5 to to make any Headway I'm not sure
if I of if E3 was really the best Square
to go but okay I have to I have to play
a move sometime don't want
to spend so long here that uh the
position becomes
irrelevant Knight
D4 yeah of course that's one possible
way here for black
forward I cannot go G5 now I
think
H maybe I can play it I mean Knight F3
Bishop F3 takes G5 Bishop
G3 Knight Knight
G4 okay maybe let's try let's try that
it's not totally clear to
me that um maybe Knight G4 intending
H6 okay this is probably not
really entirely good not very not the
correct way to attack but it is
interesting at
least D D4 is going to play C3
here okay I probably have to
take and now what to do
here I was thinking cannot really take
unfortunately
move like Knight G4 is is leading
nowhere
right G2 and F4
maybe or should it take and Bishop E2
intending Bishop D3 maybe that I'm not
I'm not not not sure about
it it's really not
clear I mean what is Cle C is that this
is not correct for white I'm definitely
worse here this this attack was was
really
fishy okay there's
still problems to solve for
black it's not entirely easy I
hope yeah he's defending he's defending
well really playing good playing
well
check D4 yeah maybe I have to do that I
can play Bishop F2 to cover
D4 yeah wants to go Rook C2
but I have some ideas it's not
like I have no attack
here G6 G6 I can play the F
Pawn
okay not not
sure he's capturing I didn't expect
that time warning to go for Rook
G1 oh I actually overlooked that it was
that that he can take it that's that's
embarrassing now he's starting to play
really
quickly okay so let's see is
there is there something that I can do
still
I have to double
somehow no that's not that's not going
to
work
yeah could have could have won
already easily but it's it's does not
matter I'm just lost
here
can just take F6
yeah can also promote King F4 is not
really
dangerous
check
check check
mate oh wow yeah that was a great start
to the session it's a new
account never played him
before yeah to be honest I just
overlooked that he can take H6 which is
really embarrassing if I play Bishop B3
here I still think I'm okay yeah okay is
so certainly certainly the case I just I
just I just Overlook that he can take it
it's very simple um around here it's uh
it's really um an unclear position um I
mean I don't know the computer likes
white even but it's it's very difficult
uh to
play Yeah I'm I mean
h yeah I just have to play Bishop E3 now
I'm lost yeah
simply I mean okay I didn't I don't want
to trade Queens but what else is there
yeah I can can stuff like that is is
going to be answered with this even I
have seven hangs but it still seems to
win yeah that wasn't any good W okay
thanks for watching